the past months have been tough for
people in Nepal the effects of the
earthquake a year ago are very much
still visible in the old royal city of
bhakta for all the historical buildings
are either damaged or completely in
ruins but the Nepalese haven't forgotten
how to party
in April the biscuit jatra festival
rings in the Hindu new year
it's the country's biggest celebration
the countryside still looks much like it
did in the weeks after the earthquake
the village of cuddled under in the
Gorkha district was at the epicenter
farmer babu basu cattle is still waiting
for aid money the government promised
him during the quake he was out in his
fields I saw a huge cloud of dust from
the field above my house at that point I
thought something big has happened and I
quickly rushed home when I reached the
house I felt another tremor the idea his
family built themselves a temporary
shelter from old wood now they want to
build a proper house their livestock
survived but their stores of corn rice
and grain were lost now they need money
and would wildfires often set
intentionally rage everywhere in Nepal
they eat their way through the mountains
and are easily visible at night animals
die because they can't escape them that
puts biodiversity at risk almost the
next day horrified villagers visit the
devastated forest just recently they had
painstakingly planted new trees gated by
a body but we don't know who's
responsible people are saying someone
was clearing his field and the fire
accidentally spread we saw it from far
away and quickly went to the spot and
tried to put it out but we couldn't it's
extremely dry everyone is waiting for
the monsoon to bring rain fires are
sparked off by cigarettes or
carelessness or deliberately laid to
clear new land for farming the
international center for integrated
mountain development is focused on
reforestation for many years it helps
locals form committees to protect the
forest you cannot conduct agriculture
here there's no water and what we want
to do is we are trying to restore this
land back into forest so the communities
have done some plantation and they look
quite fruitful but the best intentions
come to nothing where goats are
concerned there are the saplings
greatest enemies that's why they're no
longer allowed into the forest and can
only roam freely if they're closely
watched the Shepherd's now bring them
food
these measures were decided in the
forest committee the villagers regularly
discuss problems at their meetings how
much timber can be harvested a fires can
be prevented and how to deal with people
who start fires because often they have
no idea who they could be today for
instance they've decided to issue IDs so
they can control access to the forest
the success is visible this looks like a
plantation but it's not the trees grow
rapidly and they're very robust this was
a varian land say 780 is 78 years ago
and since this patch of land was handed
over to the local communities they have
developed a operational plan which they
follow and as you can see these are Yong
sul forest has regenerated naturally the
organization's project workers have told
them what would they can take and when
trees can be felled so the villagers
collect only dead wood and branches in
the forest and they keep to that it's
idiot Ursula K big nosa the forest is a
carbon reservoir protecting the climate
Nepal is preparing for the UN's REDD+
program countries that expand their
carbon reservoirs receive money from an
international fund that's why the
villagers are measuring this area how
many trees are there how tall are they
and what is their circumference for them
the concept of carbon is very new and we
want them to actually know whether the
forest is increasing or decreasing in
carbon trend and this is very important
for measurement for monitoring measuring
and reporting the carbon in their in
their community forest it gives them a
sense of ownership and it also reflects
their management if it goes
in a decreasing trend they should know
that they're not doing a good job in
terms of managing the forest regular
monitoring will take place over the
coming years to see if the forest grows
in which case there will be funding from
various sources or if it shrinks because
of fires that would be bad for the
climate nature and biodiversity